bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video io sono fan i j
oggi siamo su the midnight man era che
un invio horror fatto con lui uniti
enjoy che mi avete consigliato in
tantissimi c'è veramente troppi
praticamente consiste nel non ho capito
neanche sinceramente comunque va bene è
praticamente è un videogame basato su
l'uomo di mezzanotte dei midnight man e
non ho capito bene siamo con una candela
la grafica è quella di pizza delivery e
allora c'è scritto 000 che presentiamo a
mezzanotte perfetto ragazzi ci siamo è
tratto un paesaggio fantastico in mezzo
alla città proprio la civiltà ragazzi di
venti semaforica su conte macchina che
di notte va beh comunque consiste nel
cos'è questa roba guardaroba preminente
per aprire yo yo aperto questa mi si
aperta sotto va bene mi fa piacere ma
prima le porte a caso ragazzi siamo in
una casa e non so perché vedete così ha
visto gioco ma mi sono veramente
arrivate tantissime richieste presumo
che faccia paura perché non lo so
insomma non avreste richiesto perché
voglio volete bene lo so io che mi
volete bene ok non è non è esattamente
di visto programma ma va bene così e tv
svenderò cosa noi lasciamo l'accesa
tanto non lo guarda nessuno
c'è un ufficio benissimo un ufficio
fantastico io direi che chiamare
qualcuno non è una bruttina vero no devo
entrare su facebook ma questo sarebbe un
monitor a me sembra di una scatola vabbè
comunque io entro su facebook nel doppio
ma da allora se mi sta a casa ancora non
abbiamo concluso una mazza di niente
bello sto bagno fantasma si accende
anche l'acqua sporca [ __ ] cos'era
marco la festa non me lo aspettavo
ecco lo sapevo perché mi avete cambiato
chi cazzo era flash stein è bene non ho
ben capito cosa è successo però è
apparso qualcuno è stato fantastico
cazzo non vedo la ritornarci di dentro
va bene la rete volte non rientrarci per
bordo perché devo fare che giorno una
porta qui a prede però si è aperta e
allora mettiamoci in un angolo così non
cpa gli sta alla sprovvista bene allora
non c'è nessuno tra l'altro raga questo
è il gesto più bello che io abbia mai
visto
edy rej di fare un bel bagno fantastico
giro ei uomo molto sexy ti va di fare un
bagno con me sarei felicissimo e va bene
leviamoci di acqua prima che torni
sinceramente non ci tengo a rivederlo
chiude televisione dry al tra l'altro
acceso ma chi se ne fotte all'acqua c'è
un'altra stanza da letto e qual è il
ragazzone lo scopo di studio cos'è che
devo fare precisamente no io vado al
piano di sotto
perché non so che cosa devo fare
[Musica]
si è chiuso qualcosa da solo e non sono
stato io ma non voglio andare a
controllare io vado di san siro ci sono
cose fonte lì non ho visto è un altro
madonna ragazzi successi sono fantastici
a guardarli solo ti viene voglia di
andare a cagare fantastico e apriamo
anche la capitale tanto per sprecare un
pochettino [ __ ] io esco prima che
compaia qualcuno li dentro riesco a
cagare giusto maledetti buongiorno cento
buon uomo e molto tardi perché non se ne
torna a casa tranquilla perché aumenta
la candela
cent all'ora e tardissimo sono e
mezzanotte e mezza è già passata
mezz'ora la prima così a caso
all'improvviso
quindi secondo me se torna a casa e
meglio perché sta lì cazzo si faccia un
colpo in piscina buon uomo faccia
qualcosa ma sì lei mi dai [ __ ] c'è
un'altra porta ok perfetto ho riacceso
la la candela sembra si faccia il
cassero la prego e mezzanotte e mezza
che vuole da me qualche caso è successo
che è caduta una sedia anzi sono cadute
le sedie merda vi si no cioè fuoco
spegne cos'è faceva tutto a fuoco qui
fermi un attimo c'è anche il frigo buona
pazza che vuoto maledizione dov'è la mia
nutella
mi serve alla ragazzi c'è ancora lì e
ancora di non si fa la gente quando si
fissa sugli altri non c'è verso
c'è ma qua c'è l'altra porta posto sia
aperto veramente c'è io posso scappare
posso scappare fuori oddio no lo scafo
fuori chiede fiori giorni credi che i
gay protesta lo zio
prato qualche andrà come entrata
spiegatemi come ho fatto a entrare
raga un'assenza sto gioco loro ragazzi
abbiano capito che io non ho cos'era era
una postilla periziare cos'è che vola
ok ragazzi oddio le sedie le sedie
tentato di uccidermi
cosa sta succedendo va bè ragazzi ma
perché cazzo mi consigliate sti giochi
che senso c'hanno va beh allora sta
volando di tutto se volevo volare
qualcos'altro non lo so allora era sia
per addio cosa ma perché con le sedi a
caso va bene ogni porta sia aperto
grazie ragazzi sta diventando
inquietante ragazzi non è normale si
aprono le porte è permesso
devo lavarmi le mani e mi sto anche
cagando addosso quindi magari la
capatina accesso ce la faccio
sentite cosa e cosa fare qual è lo scopo
disco gioco stato qual è il mio
obiettivo ma posso uscire di qua no
veramente non uscirei dico anche volendo
unico ancora ci sono entrato più dentro
bene forse devo accendere su televisori
anno che sarà già accesa salve non è una
non è buona educazione e spiare la gente
di campagna
ecco cos'è
[Musica]
allora vi giuro che questo è l'ultimo
tentativo perché non ha senso 8 gioco
perché mi avete consigliato sta roba che
mi ammazzano senza che io faccia nulla
io non so che cosa devo fare
precisamente ma voglio provare ad
accendere tutto è possibile tutto anche
lavandini tutto voglio provare a far
questo perché mi sembra l'unica cosa che
possa fare perché tranne davanti le
porte non posso fare nient'altro quindi
lo faccio ok sta roba che parte però non
ho capito perché non riporta accendiamo
qualsiasi anche il fuoco vai anche il
fuoco tutto anche le sedie volate ha
veramente siete già volate di posto va
bene così frigo aperto bene tutto
accendiamo anche il microonde vai
preparare prepariamoci un panino già che
ci siamo qualcuno di voi al post
ok grazie grazie per avermi aperto la
porta così ci metto di meno vai ce la
posso fare sto prendo di tutto la lav
attesa e anche la lavatrice mi ci ficco
pure dentro volendo st portasse fortuna
si apriva bene se questa porta e finta
devo quando si è aperta starò da quando
si è aperta sta roba
ma la devo tenere aperta perché sono non
funziona allora ha chiesto televisore
vai tutto accendo qualsiasi cosa cosa
manca l'altro stanza cia posso fare la
che ci posso fare
e l'ultima l'ultima stanza e questa per
ora dopo accendere ok perfetto ci siamo
acceso tutto tranne forse sto televisore
qui si infatti questo è l'ultimo che
manca
ok adesso ufficialmente ok è
ufficialmente stronzo ecco che cosa è
brutto bastardo acceso tutto cosa vuoi
ancora cosa devo fare
raga io scappo non so se navoni da
scappare dice mente va bene non lo
faccio bene ho acceso la candela
cosa devo fare il suo gioco ragazze non
sa se allora l'acqua è accesa bene ho
acceso qualsiasi cosa non si può
chiamare qualcuno no vero non luce i
telefoni ci sono ma non li usiamo per
carità ma si sa mai che riesco a
salvarmi
poi acceso ragazzi non potevo fare vuoi
farti un bagno non lo so perché sto
girovagando come un deficiente
la voce si può accendere lo si può fare
l'allora giovane allora non so bene sto
cadendo sto facendo un casino accenni
piacente si è spenta ok perfetto è
caduto qualcosa sta accadendo di tutto
ragazzi non capisco cosa devo fare
ho aperto il tuo aperto tutto quello che
c'è da aprire bene ai sensi sottospecie
di franchi ossia il mal riuscito cosa
dovrei fare dimmelo tu è che fece
l'entrata dall altra parte magari l'hai
vista marca montana
cioè io io l'ho pensato e lui l'ha fatto
o detto ciò la porta dietro aperta non
la vede potrebbe fare giro infatti ha
fatto il giro maledizione ragazzi non ci
gioco piazza roba marchio sera il quale
lo stop visto gioco prendersi in parte
grazie grazie mille direi che posso
chiuderla qui perché è stata una cosa
impensabile
vabbè se servi dove piaciuto essere
odiata anche questo stronzo mettete un
mi piace al video e anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete quali
siti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo in un
prossimo video bella ragazzi